c
après 10 mois en captivité à
Moscou, elle est de retour aux
États-Unis. Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
- L'arrestatio B B Brittney
Griner avait provoqué
une onde de choc aux États-Unis
et dans le monde du sport.
Cela faisait des mois que
Washington négociait en coulisse
sa libération. La basketteuse
de 32 ans avait été arrêtée
puis emprisonnée à Moscou
le 17 février dernier
pour trafic de drogue.
"Aujourd'hui est une bonne
journée", dit sa conjointe,
qui a maintenu la pression
pendant neuf mois auprès
du gouvernement américain.
"C'était un moment sombre
de ma vie, dit-elle, et
je n'ai que de la gratitude
envers le président."
Les négociations ont été
intenses et douloureuses,
affirme un Joe Biden soulagé.
"Elle est en sécurité, ,,,,
et en route pour la maison."
Brittney Griner avait été
arrêtée à l'aéroport de Moscou
une semaine avant l'invasion
russe en Ukraine. Elle avait
en sa possession une vapoteuse
et du liquide contenant
du cannabis.
ététététait de la persécution
politique, dit le sénateur
démocrate Durbin, elle allait
passer plus de neuf ans
dans une prison russe."
Elle a été libérée en échange
d'un redoutable trafiquant
d'armes russe proche du Kremlin,
Viktor Bout, surnommé
le marchand de la mort.
Il purgeait une peine de 25 ans
de prison depuis 2008
aux États-Unis.
Il aurait armé entre autres les
FARC de Colombie et également
les mouvements rebelles
en Angola etririririria.
(explosion)
Paul Whelan est un autre
prisonnier américain détenu
en Russie, condamné à 16 ans
de prison pour espionnage.
Washington espérait
sa libération en même temps
que celle de Griner.
"Obtenir la libération
d'Américains détenus
illégalement est notre p
dit-il, et nous continuons
de travailler d'arrache-pied
pour ramener Paul Whelan."
En attendant, Washington
itititititite du dénouement
pour Brittney Griner.
L'échange de prisonniers
se serait produit à Abou DhabiÉ,
qui, avec l'Arabie saoudite,
ont servi de médiateurs
entre Moscou et Washington.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Bosto